where do you see things now that we're
about a month i would actually
distinguish between what we actually see
in the markets and the story that wall
street is telling the story that wall
street is telling is all optimistic
we're going to have all this boost
economic growth a lot of that seems to
me to be based upon wishful thinking if
you look at a chart that the stock
market over the past 10 years you see
this big dip with the economic crisis
and this huge rise and then there's
little further legal at the top which is
what's happened since this election that
the markets are not in fact building a
huge optimism about chop
I think they are probably under waiting
the chance of catastrophe breaks it was
another recent world event where a lot
of people in the immediate aftermath
said this is going to be an economic
catastrophe running that hasn't quite
happened yet but it sounds like maybe
what you're saying is be careful about
getting too comfortable
well actually it Rex it was a huge shock
to the European project it's the
consequences five years ten years down
the pike could be very severe it did not
put people with zero experience in
charge of running the British government
its people with long experience
competent they talk to people who are
are reasonable but it's nothing at all
like what happened here there's this
global moment that populism is having
right we're hearing that certainly here
but but in Europe as well that rise of
populist leaders you wrote recently that
that term is is somewhat miss attributed
to Donald Trump in the sense then in his
first few weeks he has pretty much been
citing economically with big business
versus the individuals the populace we
can meet a bunch of things and normally
when you say populism you have in mind
someone who is is a fact on it soak the
rich and do all kinds of stuff for the
populace and is doesn't care about the
elite